Jojo is exploding back onto the music
scene with a catchy new single and her
first full-length album in 10 years but
the 25 year olds lzt it's been a rocky
road fad did you ever think I'm my
career's done yeah did I thought how can
I come back from this
how can I you know too much time has
passed I've had many low points honestly
I was depressed I was drinking a lot I
was I just wanted to to feel good and
get out of my mind and that was
obviously trying to fill a hole that um
that I had Jojo first taught the charge
when she was just 13 but problems with
her former label halted her career so I
had to sue twice spent all my time and
money to get to the other side of it
when you talked about a low point when
your record label asked you to be on
diet supplements and that you are only
eating 500 calories a day so I was 18
and I was told that if I didn't look a
certain way that they wouldn't put out
my music so I was like oh if if this is
gonna make my music come out then okay I
was on shots like I was injecting myself
with this thing from this dietician that
makes it so you're not hungry and it
tricks your body into thinking you're
pregnant
so then what the food that it would give
the baby it ends up like expelling I
wasn't even done growing necessarily but
because I wanted my career to move
forward and I was so scared I I did it
and and it just made me feel like well I
am I not good enough of a singer am I
not special enough did you have an
eating disorder did that develop at all
in any way this is how sick this is but
I wished at that time that I could
develop an eating disorder that I I
don't think that now so please don't
take that out of context but I because I
was so frustrated with myself that I was
eating but no I didn't you know nothing
that I felt I
really put a name to now Jojo is making
it clear that she came out on the other
side stronger than ever
girl I had a lot to overcome but I'm not
just tough what aren't you apologizing
for anymore but loving who I love for
doing what I need to do for being hungry
for chasing after my dreams I'm really
not sorry for - being myself
[Music]